Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era
of discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
and lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today I wanted to talk about
the topic of foundational models
for fluids or for computational
fluid dynamics.
It's a topic that I brought up
and asked quite a few of the
people that I interviewed
recently.
But I, I wanted to give some
personal thoughts on this,
partially because I had the
pleasure a couple of weeks ago
of chairing a panel discussion
at the second data-driven fluid
dynamics conference, which was
an ERCOFTAC Euromech thing
that was done at Imperial College
London.
I was involved in the first one
in Paris the previous year.
And it's a great initiative that
has tried to bring the fluids
community and I guess the AI
community together, particularly
with a sort of European flavour,
I guess to it.
But in this panel session, it
was really interesting because
we had representatives from, you
know, Harvard, but also Caltech
and, and some from industry and,
and really representing the
experimental and the
computational side.
And one of the things that I did
was to try and ask people about
their opinion of foundational
models.
But more interestingly or as
interesting was I tried to ask
the audience some of the
questions and there was a couple
of hundred people in the audience.
And so we use this Mentimeter
app that I have to confess I
haven't really used before, but
it's great because you can
essentially do real-time polling
of people.
So I asked the question, do you
believe that we will have
foundational models?
And in fact, I'm just looking on
the on the screen now because I
have the results up.
Well, I should tell you, the
first thing I did ask was what's
your favorite British food?
Bit of a tongue-in-cheek really.
And fish and chips
won, followed secondly by the
vomit emoji, which I was a bit
offended by.
And then a full English
breakfast.
So there we go.
But more seriously, on the
actual topic of foundational
models, I basically said, will
you know, can we get
foundational model for fluids?
How generalisable could it be?
And what I asked was, could it?
Could this foundational model
provide instantaneous pressure,
velocity for any boundary
condition or geometry?
So as in you can say to it
here's a geometry with a certain
boundary condition, can it
predict it and give you the
instantaneous pressure and
velocity?
A bit like a CFD solver.
Now you give it a geometry, you
give it some boundary
conditions, and it would go and
solve it.
Second option I gave people is
exactly the same, but time
averaged.
So not instantaneous, but time
averaged, and I'll get into the
nuance of that in a little bit.
Then the third option was yes,
but only for a specific use
case, as in maybe like a road,
car or a plane.
And finally, option was
essentially no physics.
Sorry fluids are just too
complex for an AI model to
learn.
And interestingly, out of the
scores it was 38 and this is out
of 100 and something.
So the the the most popular
answer was only for a specific
use case. 38 people close 2nd.
37 was provide time average to
any boundary condition or geometry
followed by instantaneous
pressure.
And finally 13 had fluids that
are just too complex.
So out of that audience, which
is biased because they are
researchers looking at fluids
and AI, the sense was it really
is only possible for a specific
use case.
And therefore the terminology of
foundational model is perhaps
pushing it a little bit or needs
redefining.
OK.
So that's why essentially I
wanted to to talk about it and I
wanted to share I guess some
opinions of my own, some stuff
I've seen along the way.
I'm in a lucky position, I
guess.
I'm working in the tech sector
that I get to engage with a lot
of customers and academics from
different groups.
So I like to go to
conferences.
And I'd like to say I'd
therefore have a reasonably
good view of what's going on in
the community.
And I would actually say that
things are looking very
interesting as in only a couple
of years ago there was really no
work into this idea of a
foundational model.
And another way of thinking of
foundational model is simply a
pretrained model.
So what most people were looking
at was simply can we come up
with some sort of algorithm,
some architecture that could
allow somebody to go and train
an AI model based on prior
simulation data.
So we're not talking about
accelerating an existing code,
we're talking about replacing
the code with a surrogate model.
And that was certainly the main
focus probably five years ago or
four years ago.
And there was some seminal work
done with things like Mesh-
GraphNets and others which took a
graph neural net approach where
you could essentially take the
nodes of the mesh as the input.
And that was something or
particles I guess because it was
all particle examples of this.
And this rapidly became one of
the success stories in the
weather and climate, but also
was showing potential for CFD.
And this led to a number of
start-ups that that formed over
the time, the sort of NAVASTO,
Neural Concept and others who
took some of this work or
pioneered things themselves and,
and released some of those
things that people could go and,
and try for themselves.
And so you saw in the past, you
know, several years, people
really wanting to test out those
methods and with some success
for sure.
But obviously that requires you
to have your own training data,
your own ability to train a
model and to have, I guess, both
the software and the knowledge
to do it.
And I guess if you can compare
that against what you would
typically see in the LLM space
where the majority of us are not
training our own LLMs, but we
are simply doing a prompt and
asking a question, doing an
inference, we're not training
it.
The logical question was, well,
could it be possible to train a
model and then just provide it
to people as a pretrained
model?
And it's a really interesting
discussion because it has pretty
large it, it could have a
potentially very large impact on
the CFD community.
Now, there are some of you out
there who still have very
negative opinions of AI and sort
of seeing it as a fad, and it will come
and go.
But I would say those voices are
slowly starting to be overtaken
by the realization that actually
these methods have a lot of
potential.
Only, like I said, five years
ago this was basically not
happening.
Nobody was even talking about
it.
I remember I got involved maybe
three years ago in this topic,
so still quite late to the game
I guess.
But even three years ago I
remember most people had no idea
what this was all about.
They just thought of this as
like reduced order modelling
ROMs, really no sense of what was
going on, didn't know what
architectures would work.
There was only maybe one or two
start-ups in the space, wasn't
very prominent.
Fast forward to now and I would
say that it is certainly rapidly
expanding and I would say
companies can be categorised as
either trying to lead in this
way, being very interested and
the number who were just set
against it is now sort of
getting lower.
But I would say that this is
still a little bit split between
the industries.
And like with there's a bit of a
parallel with high fidelity
methods, I see the automotive
sector as being much faster to
adopt these new technologies or
investigate these new
technologies.
Automotive companies today use
hybrid RANS, scale-
resolving methods on a
day-to-day basis, whereas the
aerospace sector is still sort
of proving out that they think
they can be used in in
production.
And some of that is because
Reynolds numbers and
complexities.
Another is just a mindset, I
believe.
And interestingly, I see the
same thing with AI. I see
that the automotive companies
are far more motivated to try
and find AI approaches that can
be faster potentially and are
embracing it.
Whereas I see aerospace is more
in the mindset of I don't think
this can work for me.
And I guess part of me, the
reason doing this podcast
episode is really just to put
across that, and this is a
genuine, this is not influenced
by the company I work for.
These are all sort of
independent opinions, personal
thoughts, but I really do think
that these are looking
incredibly interesting for the
obvious reason that, you know,
now if you do an inference on a,
on a model, you're going to get
an answer in seconds.
But the accuracy is debatable
whether people have truly proved
out that these these AI methods
are accurate enough.
They give a very good impression
of, you know, approximately what
the flow field is or
approximately what the lift or
drag is.
But I would say that we are
still not at the case where
they're widely accepted or there
are very clear accuracy.
I would say it's a bit like CFD
in the early days where you
could argue there was clear
points where it worked well, but
there were many examples where
it didn't work.
And hence why CFD took decades,
you know, to to progress and be
trusted enough to be a dominant
design tool.
I'd say AI is still in that sense where
it's probably not trusted as a
key design tool yet.
But I would say that the number
of companies really investing in
this is significantly growing.
The number of start-ups who are
emerging in this space is
growing month on month.
And the interest from the big ISVs is also growing month on
month.
But the challenge is the data.
So do you have available data?
And this has always been the
challenge for the idea of a
foundational model, as probably
people know, you know, the
reason that these LLMs and others
can do so well is that they have
a very large data source to, to
to, to get to.
So typically scraping off the
Internet, but nowadays maybe
doing commercial deals with a
certain repository of data.
You know, if you want to do
something on journal papers, you
might do a deal with Elsevier or
John Wiley.
If you want to do something on
video, you might do a deal with
a video, you know, distributor
or or a newspaper.
If you want to do on text or
pictures, you might do with
Adobe.
You know, there's a lot of
commercial arrangements going on
now.
And I think that's what's super
interesting on the CFD side
because on one side you could
say the data is just not
available.
If you want to do combustion
modelling or multiphase or
hypersonic something.
This is not publicly available
data.
So how do you you know, how do
you solve that?
And this is where I think
there's an interesting technical
but also commercial angle to
this, which is, is it worth it
for a company to independently
run lots and lots of simulations
to the point that they can pre-
train a model and then supply
the model and, and and charge it
at a certain rate.
And we have seen some early
signs of this happening.
You know, there's a start up
Luminary Cloud.
Some people know that I spoke to
to Juan Alonso, the founder, and
they recently released a sort of
foundational model for road cars
where they'd, you know, run a
whole bunch of simulations
themselves in collaboration with
an end customer of
theirs and and then released
that and pretrained the model.
Now that it's probably too early
to see, you know, how ultimately
successful that that that will
be. But they've sort
of fired the starting gun, so to
speak, on an actual company
releasing a sort of pretrained
model.
And I think it's really
interesting to observe how
useful that is because on one
side, it removes a massive
barrier for a company to to
collect all the data, find all
the data to have the expertise to
use an AI tool.
It's much easier just to do
inference on a pretrained model.
So I think that's the first
thing I predict that we're going
to see many more of those come
out.
Many more companies will will,
will do that both I think from the
startup and ISV space.
But how, how much data can a
company generate and how can
they incentivize it?
Well, one interesting thing,
when I spoke with Prith, who's
the CTO of Ansys, he said in one
of the talks that I gave that,
you know, maybe the ISV needs to
incentivize people to allow the
ISV to have the data.
So I think that's a really
interesting proposition that,
you know, what if you would tick
a box that was to say, well, you
know, as you run your CFD
simulation, I give permission
for the ISV to use that data and
perhaps in return they get, you
know, some commercial incentive
to do it.
And I think that's a really
interesting proposition.
And I'm, I'm, I'm keen to see if
some of the ISVs go down that
route.
And this actually links why I've
often spoken about the cloud
being an important avenue and the
cloud being an important avenue
links to this because of the SaaS
bit.
If you give somebody a on-prem
binary, even if they tick some
box to say we're happy for you
to look at our data, what's the
mechanism to share that file?
Well, it's pretty difficult
because it's running on their
local network.
How are they going to, you know,
send that over to you?
It's not practical where with a
SaaS solution, it's much easier
because it's by definition
running in, let's say someone's
cloud.
And so if you say I want to
share some of my data with them,
it's actually much easier to do
it.
So I predict that part of the
motivation and I think we'll see
an acceleration of the
SaaSification is to make this
sort of AI and data collection
easier both.
If you're an existing AI start-
up, you know, you could say,
hey, use my AI tool and I'll
give you a discount if you share
your training data with me and
over time will collect more
data.
And also it links into one of
the things I've said repeatedly
on this podcast about fast CFD
solvers or CAE solvers.
Because now one of the big
things is if you've got to
generate 5000 CFD cases, if your
CFD solver is twice as fast as
another CFD solver, that's a big
amount of money to save.
Or for the same budget, you
could run twice as many cases.
So if we assume that, to
build these foundational models
will have to run hundreds of
thousands of cases, then
actually there will be a huge
focus on on enabling the code to
be as efficient as possible.
Now, one of the other things
that I haven't brought up, but I
think is another interesting one
is everything I've spoken about
now assumes that the CFD code is
independent from the AI code.
But as anybody knows anything
about, for example, in-situ
visualisation, we'll know that
there's a strong move now
towards this idea of doing it,
you know, online rather than
saving everything to disk and
then doing the visualisation.
Can you do it whilst it's
running?
And this is obviously something
that's not just me, you know,
saying this for the first time,
it's known that I think there'll
be a big increase, and there already is,
certainly in the academic world
of trying to build your CFD code
in the same framework as your AI
code.
Some groups are doing this in
PyTorch, you know, how do I
write a code in there?
Or they're using some sort of
Python code that you can
automatically, you know,
differentiate and move between
to pass gradients along and to
the neural networks.
But I predict this will be a
will be important because if you
are trying to build some pretrained model, some sort of
foundational model, you don't
really want to be doing your CFD
independently to your AI
training.
You want them to be tightly
coupled and potentially adding
more points as you need them and
not having to be, you know,
bound by I/O issues, having to
keep the data.
Which is particularly true if
you have the dream, and I think
this is a much longer term dream
of being able to do
instantaneous.
So time dependent, most training
now is done on time average
solutions, even if it's a time
accurate simulation, because
just the amount of data, I mean
having created with colleagues,
you know the DrivAerML dataset,
it's already 30 terabytes with
one time step essentially as in
the time averaging, if you were
going to try and do it for all
of them, 200,000 iterations,
well, you can do the maths, it's
unbelievably large.
But if at every time we were
running those simulations, we
were passing that data to a
model to train, then, of course,
we don't need to save the time
steps out.
We're just passing it in memory.
So we actually could have done
it because we were running the
simulations time-
dependent anyway.
So I think this is where there's
a lot of interest in these.
I feel this is where new
technologies are converging with
AI as the sort of motivating
factor.
So foundational models.
I, I really would encourage any
academic who's listening to
this, I think this is the topic
to propose as a, you know, a big
university project or European
project or government project
or, you know, anything that is
big.
Because if this could be made
and there's so many debates on whether it
should be open source, should be
closed source.
It could transform the way that
we are doing CFD today.
If it is possible, it would
change the commercial landscape,
it would change the technical
landscape.
And if you imagine that it's
possible for a certain class of
applications, you've got to
imagine the transfer learning,
the fine tuning.
You know, at some point how
different is a car than a plane
or a city if you are starting
with, if the model is able to
learn some of these
interactions.
I haven't really spoken about
the idea of including physics
into it, but I I really do feel
that just as five years ago AI
was an interesting thing for
people to look at, I think the
whole concept of foundational
models is becoming interesting.
I believe at the beginning it
will be for specific use cases as
the audience voted, but I
perceive that there will be a
bit of an arms race between the
ISVs and startups to
build this, and it'll be
interesting to see whether
companies see this as their
secret sauce.
Whether you know, an aerospace
manufacturer or an automotive
manufacturer says, well, I don't
need the ISV, I'm going to do it
myself.
And this will be an interesting
balance between the software
suppliers, the companies,
because on the other hand, the
automotive company can say,
well, we're not a software,
we're a car designer.
Why are we going to write our
own codes?
And that's certainly been the
case even in the aerospace.
There's a move towards
commercial codes.
Well, you know, it used to be
the case, everybody would write
their own codes and that was
their IP.
And then they realised their IP
is making cars or planes, not
writing software.
So it, I still suspect that most
of this work, these foundation models
will still make their way into
commercial sort of big software
companies, ISVs.
But given that they don't have
the data, it's the sort of
engineering companies who have
the data and they need to
somehow get that data or produce
that data.
There'll be an interesting
dynamic, I think in
collaboration.
So these are just my personal
thoughts.
I could be completely wrong, but
I am quite bullish on the idea
of some of these foundational
models.
And, and certainly, you know, in
my day job, this is something
I'm actively pursuing.
I'm I'm academically interested.
I'm interested in, you know,
NVIDIA doing its bit to help
things along the way.
And yeah, I'll be really
interested to see what happens
in a few years time.
So maybe I I'll try and set a
reminder in two years to record
another one and see how much of
this.
I was right on and maybe it was
it'll all not happen and I was
completely wrong.
But I'm, I'm going to make a bet
that in a couple of years we
will have progressed quite a bit
further than than than we have
done to date.
So with that, thanks for thanks
for listening.
I would really enjoy your
comments.
Let me know what you think if
I'm completely wrong, if you
have a different viewpoint on
it, please put your comments in
the YouTube or, or send me a
message.
And yeah, thanks for listening
and hope you enjoyed it.